i old were you when you first shot
somebody i first shot somebody was
probably around I guess 18 something
like that 18 19 and that's God I like
seriously do something to you when
you're doing something you're doing that
that young like violence at that age
it's got to change it's gonna you know
you grow up in an area where I was one
of the slow walkers what you would say
as far as committing crimes or killing
or hurtin guys actually I had a slew of
friends cousins my cousins my friends
they were all a lot more dangerous than
me so I was a little more of a slow
Walker okay
and as crazy as that seems I mean later
on i bypass everybody and I start
becoming the guide it's doing all this
work and one by one my cousins are
getting killed my friends are getting
killed and I'm out doing the work and
killing and and moving towards the
hierarchy of the Gambino family Wow how
many how how many people would you say
that you ended up shooting or killing
you know again I I just spouted out as
food out on the value entertainment
names places dates witnesses of what I
did not yell back probably about 25
shootings I could continue with and you
know we're doing shows movies and a lot
of that stuff and dates and times and
places we're saving for the actual films
that are coming out the we're doing a
series coming out yeah I guess that's a
big question I mean judging by you know
your past and like the violence and and
all the criminal violence that you were
involved in all the shootings and
killings and the jail time you did I
mean obviously those are super
interesting stories but so why do this
so why come out in the media and why
talk about all this and and and tell the
story like why do this well because
here's one of the reasons when I first
was in court during the trials the Gotti
family that lawyer said I shot about 60
guys so I never denied any how many
people I shot how many people I heard
how many people like baseball bat it
stabs I mean I was very famous for
saying yes I did you know so I don't
deny that
I took in the streets but you know one
of the things people know that I do now
is try to help kids not to follow that
path and follow those footsteps and save
themselves a lot of pain and anguish and
maybe save their life so I'm out there
publicly doing talks at colleges at
schools high schools at the juvenile
census and my thing is to try to help
some kids save the lives around the
world and you know I've been around the
world talks in Switzerland I've done
talks in the UK of Dunham's in New York
New Jersey Philadelphia okay this area
in Tampa Florida and I'm doing lectures
all over and and trying to you know give
people the real of what goes on within
the streets what goes on within the
Mafia and murders and you know the
everyday life of being a criminal mm-hmm
and you said you also said that you're
you're pretty close friends with Sammy
the bull Sammy is a guy that obviously
was an underboss it again being a family
most people know if you don't know him
you can look him up and he's just
recently done an interview value
entertainment which I also done a couple
weeks prior to him and you get the basis
of his story mine and some of the things
we discuss and talk about and Sammy was
very powerful on the boss and the
Gambino family very powerful guy in the
street and he was portrayed and torn you
know the problem with the street and the
street world is people that don't really
understand it and they watch some TV or
they listen to these shows they think
they really understand what you sign up
for and how a treacherous it is and they
really don't get it but if you sat at a
table with this well you came in a room
like this and you sat with us that
opinion that everybody spoons out so you
know easily on a computer when would be
slid back about 30 steps they wouldn't
be speaking like that so you know the
guys that do understand the life and
understand the treachery it's uh
Makaveli times 20 if you know what
Machiavelli is if you ever read and and
it's it's a treacherous life and the
reason why we're out here doing this
stuff obviously some of the things I do
magazines movies series TV series you do
get paid for but
the drive for me to do this or any of
the things I do at schools yeah out of
trying to help kids and it's not for
money it's not monetary I don't get paid
for it and that I'm not trying to get
paid for it mm-hmm so it's just two kids
to help save somebody's life oh wow
that's strong you man I mean I
appreciate you doing that I appreciate
you taking your time to share these
stories I mean what kind of what kind of
lesson like if you could talk go talk to
yourself back then if you could say
something to yourself back when you were
18 years old like what was one of the
big what's the biggest lesson that you
learned from that whole experience from
from when you first started drug dealing
and shooting people and all your time in
prison like what's been your biggest
lesson well my biggest lesson if I can
wake up again it'd be 14 years old and
innocent I'd be saying to myself what
the [ __ ] are you thinking yeah you know
because when I wake up and you know most
kids are going to the beach I was going
to Train I was going to run I was going
up to push-ups and work out to play
baseball I was a full you know I was a
big ball player baseball player boxer
but I took all those training tips and
it became a violent guy you know back in
guy he's taking guys heads off stabbing
guys and really I'd have to say what
exactly what I just said not repeating
what the [ __ ] am I thinking why am I out
there not enjoying life and that's the
message really when you're talking to
kids is there's so many good things you
could do with yourself go to the beach
life's beautiful travel go to country to
country like I did but don't give me any
money to do all that right well not
necessarily I mean this kids all you
know that go especially in European kids
they go abroad and they go from hostel
to hostel they need a group of kids you
save a couple bucks you go by train you
hike or walk you take buses you could do
it on a trip cheap route but it go
experience the world that's the
difference and I mean listen you can
always you know there's kids at young
kids you know deliver newspapers go
hustle around legitimate be a way to be
a busboy you know work in stores you
know work on trucks what else yeah you
don't need a hundred grand to go travel
Europe you can get cheap tickets and go
live life but the idea is the more you
experience life the more you experience
different countries
you understand the world a little better
and maybe you want and risk your life so
easily like a lot of us do yeah and you
know you get a lot of the inner-city
kids that I speak up for that you know
you talk about Oprah Winfrey will use
for an example and the inner-city kids
you're out in Africa and I feel bad for
what goes on in Africa but if he wants
to donate money what's wrong without
kids here in the United States donated
he helped the kids here helped the
school system and help everybody get the
right direction there's a lot of famous
people out there that do the right thing
and she has wanted them but I think it
needs to start here and I in our country
where there's so many kids that need a
helping hand and I think that's where it
should be you know that's where it
should start not as not outside the
country can you kind of give me the gist
or give me the backstory of what the
relationship was between you and John
Gotti Jr well you know I was a guy that
was put in position to you know take
care of him protect him and we had
fallen out so over the years his father
was in a position whether you like him
as a boss or not became a boss and
although I disagreed on his leadership
in a lot of ways he was a gangster the
son on the other hand was what I call
spoiled brat
all right guys make fun of him chrome
type of diaper Don now many different
things because of what he does with the
media as far as you know social media
I'm talking about he doesn't get on he
just did it they just made a movie about
him right they did a movie and made a
movie about his father
tanked about his father okay with John
Travolta John Travolta was a disaster of
a film they say was the worst film ever
in the history of Mark really but again
because the son trying to hold and
control the what was you know being
written how was being written and you
know he destroyed whatever they were
trying to do with the movie by trying to
control it so this is the problem with
them he's uh doesn't do anything where
he comes out in a positive manner tries
to help some kids doesn't come out and
be truthful you know we have to just
what I did I had to catch him
as an informant and there's there's no
way listen your informant there's no way
to back out of that you're Queen of the
day there's no way to say only write it
a little bit or you know these
ridiculous comments and I hate to always
go into it about him because he's
nothing to me and in my country in
Albanian is a terminology for a barking
dog you know you ever see these little
dogs like a little chihuahua they don't
stop stop yapping and barking and you
know we say just keep walking and keep
walking passing that dog is gonna be
walking forever right yeah so you know
he's a Balkan he's a guy that you know
never did no work you know he wasn't
violent in the street the guys like me
did that stuff and he's on a pony
syndrome nobody wants to hear that you
know stand on your own two feet say
listen I lived a life I shouldn't have
we dealt drugs yeah maybe I didn't buy
my own hand go out and hurt all these
guys but guys like me did and right you
know do something positive our kids stop
whining and crying stop blaming your
father for putting in this life yeah and
then you tried to you know make money
off your father's legacy or whatever you
whether you agree with the lifestyle of
his father or how he led which you know
I'm not a big advocate as him as a
leader but the father was of hammers
or is that the fall is leadership I mean
the son I don't even really there's no
like talking about money no there's
really not much to say a little
something left to say do you think that
you guys will ever mend the relationship
I mean we got were you guys were pretty
good friends at one point right I don't
know if you're friends I know the media
said we're friends and okay I said you
know what times yeah we were friends but
you know I work with them it was a
working relationship and you know I won
depends on how I feel that day I say I
babysit him you know he's just a spoiled
guy you know until he faces that the
truth about himself that he was spoiled
that he was kind of a bratty kid food
spread you know fed and spoon fed and
you know I'm not gonna have so many good
things to say about him until he steps
up Pisa you know it becomes a man and
does the right thing with kids
and you know stops [ __ ] and
everybody and you know just say hey
listen if there's a way to change that
you were queen in a day I just want to
know about it but there really is no way
to change that you work Weiner today
well I was in Penitentiary's and other
guys and you started talking giving us
up we don't know exactly how many times
you met and we don't know if it's for
years but you were an informant and
there's no way changing that you took
yourself in and met with the government
and he's trying to spin it somehow and
there's no street guy not one that will
say anything different but that he was
an informant and cooperate or ID or any
dumb word that he uses
so Queen so the term Queen of the day is
basically a rat or a snitch yeah yeah
same thing yeah well you've never heard
that one before yeah it's well you're
not a gangster so that's you good
observation yes so if you're in the
street we all know what it there's no
excuse for it you made it an appointment
to meet the government you clean it a
day you're a rat snitch whatever inform
it so guys like and that's the bank he's
trying to sell something to guys like
you that don't know what all this is
okay so gangsters know what it is and
Street guys criminals and so you know
there is no change you know the problem
is with most kids younger kids when they
get well on the street they don't
understand informants they don't
understand with this thing with ten kids
don't think that somebody's never you
know he's a stand-up guy by the street
mentality stand-up guy and he's not
going to talk to the police but then
there's three cause of the guys are
going into the police and they're given
information and people don't know it
[Laughter]